all right we're all prisoners of time we
can't completely escape the aging
process but there are ways to Stave off
some of its effects including hormone
balancing here to talk more about that
is Erica Loren of parasol ascetics Erica
thanks for being here today thanks for
having me let's talk about this
treatment and what sets you apart
so I do a lot of bioidentical hormone
therapy which is bhrt so it's actually
different than Western medicine hormone
therapy which is synthetic so if you go
to your regular doctor the hormones like
estrogen are made from a pregnant Mare's
horse like horse urine so what I use is
actually made from vegetable root like
yam so it goes into the body easier it's
used easier and it helps with all of
those symptoms like that you get as you
age so perimenopause andropause
menopause and andropause is men right so
this is for men and women is the
treatment the same for both sexes or are
there differences now the treatment is
different because men are tend to be
more testosterone related so
testosterone decline in men starts at
age 30. you can actually lose about one
to two percent a year going up into
metal age so most guys will notice like
they'll kind of get that like belly
Pudge less muscle fatigue loss of libido
I had one guy come in before and he's
like I'm crying all of a sudden that
Titanic and I never was before so he's
like help me and the idea is to bring
people's hormone levels back to where
they were around the age of 30 right yes
so we bring you back so those things
like especially women can start going
into perimenopause around age 35 10
years before you go into menopause so
symptoms like that foggy brain and also
the waking for women and like memory
loss and you kind of Wonder like what's
going on with yourself these are things
that actually can be alleviated not
totally cured but they can 60 70 better
with treatments people come in for an
assess and then they start the treatment
about how long does it take for the
effects to kick in or to get back to
that hormone level that you're shooting
for even Within
within of therapy you're feeling a lot
better women are like are like I'm
sleeping better at night
um maybe they're like nudging their
significant other during the middle of
the night like they feel quite a bit
better so everybody wins right yes both
sides all right Erica I appreciate you
joining us uh so much you can call
parasol Aesthetics Dermatology and
wellness at that phone number right
there
702-560-6776 or you can visit
parasolcompanies.com they have a special
offer right now free initial hormone
balancing consultation with laboratory
orders you can use the code on your
screen
b-h-r-t now and if you didn't get that
down really quickly just go to our
website we have all that information for
you Mercedes